e
même engagement avait été pris
en 2014. Elle était dans les
faits?
Normand Grondin.
aut protégaut protégaut protégas
pour sauver le climat : une
centaine de paysis
d'accord au sommet de Glasgow,
en Écosse, pour mettre un frein
à la déforestation d'ici 2030.
Les signataires
également engagés à verser
plus de 19 milliards $ pour
la restauration des zones vertes
L'entondiales, dont les
plus grands propriétaires sont
la Rusine, les États-
Unis, le Brésil, le Congo
et, bien sûr, le Canada.
Elle a été bien reçue en général
malgré une certaine dose
Des pays comme le Brésil
uent de raser
quotidiennement leur forêt et
globalement, la forêt mondialeat
de 27 terrains de football
chaque minute, selon les- Dans ,
la Russie a promis de protéger
la carboneutralité en 2060,
et le Congo, un pays couvert
de jungles tropicales, affirme
qu'il va assurer communautés los
et des peuples autochtones.
FÉLIX TSHISEKEDI, prés.
République démocratique du Congo
- Nous dans notre stratégie
d'industrialisation,
d'investissements agricoles et
dans la gouvernance forestière.t
est en moins bon état qu'on le
croit, selon Gre l'exploitation
intensive, les incendies
et d'autres facteurs sont
sous-estimés dans l'évaluation
environnementale
OLIVIER KOLMEL
Greenpeace Canada
- Ce qui est surprenant puis
qu'on uement, je dirais,
au Canada, c'est que nos forêts,
dans les dernières années, ont
inversées : elles sont devenues
non plcarboncarboncarboncarboncs
de carbone et ça, c'est dû à
déforestation et à une mauvaise
gestion de nos forêts.
recouvrent la Terre capturent
actuellement près du q
des émissions de gaz à effets
de serre que nous produisons.
ICI Normand Grondin,
Radio